hallo ich meine lieben villiger buddies
und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
folge crafting ideen heute samstag diese
ganzen anderen serien wie top 5 oder
kräftigen ideen habe ich mir gedacht
haben keinen richtigen wochentag weil
ich die man ab und zu mache sie kommen
aber in etwa immer so wöchentlich aber
ich würde sagen er wieder richtig
richtig viele kommentare geschrieben
aber an über 1000 kommentare unter der
letzten folge mit ganz vielen crafting
ideen und ich habe mir fünf coole
rausgesucht und ich würde sagen die
kohle platin habt schreibt mir die
kommentare bleibt auf jeden fall bis zum
ende dran ball richtig coole sachen
diesmal dabei sind und dann fangen wir
direkt an mit der ersten sache thomas
schreibt einen rucksack crafting
außenrum leder und in der mitte eine
truhe der platz 3 x 3 weil so ein
rucksack könnte op sein und lesen bevor
man meckert ich weiß es gibt muss wo man
ein rucksack hat aber sehr viel besser
wenn es den rucksack ab der 1.8 und
1.1.1 schon gibt denn viele wissen nicht
wie man modern leute und das ist nämlich
eine sache die ich schon sagen wollte
viele leute schreiben wenn man die
kommentare
entweder es ist ok oder b ja das gibt es
schon an der und der modifikation ich
weiß freunde allerdings sind es sachen
die ich mir wünsche die in vanilla
survival minecraft hinzugefügt werden
und nicht durch irgendwelche mods also
es gibt natürlich auch mods die
irgendwie das und das hinzufügen aber
dann denke ich mir sony da stelle ich
doch nicht vor weil das will ich nicht
in minecraft darin haben dass es
vielleicht ganz witzig aber ich finde
erstmalig zeigt euch jetzt erst mal das
crafting rezept wie man das ganze mit
kräftig und zwar halt einfach wieder
thomas auch schon geschrieben hat
außenrum leder in die mitte eine kiste
dann hat man diesen braunen rucksack den
er eingeblendet sehen und so das ganze
würde dann dreimal 3 platz haben also
sowieso ein crafting feld sondern ein
bisschen extra platz halt quasi und ich
weiß wir hatten
bei hexe damals bei miro hatten wir eine
modifikation drin wo diese rucksäcke
auch dann waren das fand ich extrem geil
wenn man sich mal einen rucksack mit dem
content da ganz viele sachen packen
konnte ich würde das ganze allerdings
wirklich nicht so groß machen wie bei
minecraft wechseln weil er konnte man
zehn millionen sachen in die rucksäcke
reinpacken und alles mögliche und ja das
auf jeden fall platz nummer eins und
bitte also nicht platz nummer eins
sondern der erste crafting idee
kommentar gewesen
bitte schreibt einfach nicht in die
kommentare oder das gibt's doch schon in
der und der modifikation ich weiß dass
es das schon gibt und viele seiten gibt
es schon in anderen modifikationen preis
enthaltene den nicht wir wandeln möchten
wir machen weiter mit der zweiten sache
die kraft oder lg kraft schreibt
crafting idee eine art flugzeug das wie
ein kart mit einer fehde mit und einen
diamanten drüber und rechts und links
ein netter stars damit das nicht so
billig ist gebaut wird hat er
wahrscheinlich vergessen wie seht ihr
jetzt auf das crafting rezept und zwar
so weit ich ihn verstanden habe war
unten ein mein kater über eine feder in
der mitte und darüber ein diamant ich
bin mir bei dir bei dem crafting deshalb
zwei sachen nicht so sicher die er
gesagt hat und zwar weiß ich nicht ob
die beiden männer statt in der mitte
links und rechts sind oder oben links
und rechts habe ich denke das ist auch
relativ egal
und das meint ob das mic hat wirklich
dabei ist ich denke mal schon und ich
würde es auch denke ich so bauen
es gibt schon modifikationen da wieder
zur erste sache zu sprechen zu kommen wo
flugzeuge hinzugefügt werden allerdings
werden diese flugzeuge die
modifikationen viel viel komplizierter
gebaut als man musste erstmal flügel
kräften und rollen und alles möglich und
so was einfach für minecraft vanilla war
schon geil weil ich denke es ich glaube
es gibt nichts in minecraft was wo man
sich erst das craften muss und dann da
sondern vereint man die beiden sachen
macht da sondern macht man das und das
wieder zusammen und dann bekommt man
etwas raus ich glaube das gibt es dann
nicht in minecraft
ich bin mir nicht sicher allerdings
finde ich dass das schon etwas sehr sehr
teures ist also mit einem diamanten zwei
netter stars das ist schon relativ teuer
allerdings und flugzeug verbrauch dann
auch dementsprechend ich würde sagen
kohle also man muss dann kohle in das
flugzeug rein tun damit das ganze auch
schwebt und so fand ich auf jeden fall
richtig richtig cool wenn das
hinzugefügt wird und das ist sache
2 dank an dich eine praktische kräftigen
idee eine ender map in der mitte eine
map und an allen freien plätzen änderte
man kann sich mit ihren die stellen
teleportieren die sich auf der karte
befinden dann muss man nicht die halbe
welt durchfliegen / rennen
vielleicht wäre es cool da noch die
koordinaten angezeigt werden vielleicht
wenn man die map vergrößert also dieser
kommentar wurde mir zugesendet von red
firefox und ich finde es extrem cool und
ich kenne auch noch keine modifikationen
die das so wirklich hinzugefügt hat und
zwar einfach eine ändern ihr seht das
crafting rezept jetzt eingeblendet das
ganze ist einfach eigentlich relativ
simpel gebracht dass wir brauchen halt
achtender perlen im kreis gelegt und
eine karte eine karte ist nicht so
schwer die einer perle muss man einfach
ein paar ändern enthüllten und dann ist
diese karte die kommt dabei raus dies so
ein bisschen lieber angehäuft so ein
bisschen grün lila bläulich so ein
bisschen ender planmäßig und dann kann
man halt wenn man die karte nimmt und
quasi so vor sich hat hat man diese
karte in der hand und sieht dann darauf
ihr die ganzen punkte auf einer karte
hat ganz normal wie wenn man eine karte
macht und da kann man einfach irgendwo
rechts drauf machen und sich dann
dahinter reportieren dass wir auf jeden
fall richtig richtig cool fände ich weil
man dann beispielsweise wenn man da
hinten im opfern hat weil da hinten und
nobs bonner band aber da vorne auf der
andern seite ist mein haus muss man
nicht mehr sonne langem ein kart strecke
beispielsweise machen sondern kann sich
einfach teleportieren
und das finde ich auf jeden fall richtig
richtig cool danke an dich red firefox
und das war sache nummer drei ich rede
immer so viel hintereinander und so
schnell dass ich immer richtig viel
spucke mehr im mund ansammelt 4 wurde
mir zu gesamt bzw in die kommentare
geschrieben von thomas und zwar meint
umarow wie wär's mal mit panzerglas
fragezeichen
es wäre zwar ein bisschen überteuert
aber und jetzt kommt das crafting rezept
und zwar obsidian außen herum und
klassen damit und jetzt seht ihr das
crafting rezept doch noch mal richtig
eingeblendet ihr seht dass da gerade
schon einfach obsidian außen herum und
in der mitte ein glas es ist sehr sehr
teuer
allerdings kommt dann so ein etwas lee
landes glashaus also seinen lila
gefärbtes glas eventuell noch so ein
bisschen
nicht dass also dieses lila gefärbt die
glatze komplett komplett lila gefärbt
und das sind jetzt quasi nur diese
streifen sind lila und das ist dann
einfach ein glas was wenn man das kaputt
machen möchte würde ich sagen also erst
da keine erklärung bei geschrieben was
das bringen würde
aber ich find's cool wenn man versucht
dieses glas kaputt zu machen ist es wie
mit obsidian und zwar es ist quasi
obsidian durch das man durchgucken kann
das ist glaube ich eine ganz gute
beschreibung also es sieht aus wie glas
allerdings hat es die haltbarkeit von
obsidian hat wenn das einer kaputt
machen will muss er zehn jahre mit einer
diamant spitzhacke gegen schlagen oder
mit der faust braucht man glaube ich für
obsidian mehrere minuten eventuell sogar
ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher wie
lange dafür braucht allerdings ist das
ganze hat wirklich so panzerglas was man
richtig wofür man richtig lang gebaut
das kaputt zu machen führen krieg
richtig gut und das ganze teil hält doch
tnt stand und alles mögliche aber es ist
auch dementsprechend teuer und das ist
auf jeden fall sache nur vier games
fried niklas schreibt einen verwandter
damit kann man sich in dem opfer wandeln
auf dem man rechts klickt er sieht aus
wie ein lohn statt bloß halt etwas
bläulicher dann beschreibt er mir das
ganze crafting rezept das ist übrigens
richtig richtig cool immer dass ihr das
schon automatisch zu macht und immer so
beschreibt und nicht so sagt ja außenrum
das und ich finde es nämlich so viel
cooler wenn man damit so buchstaben
arbeiteten wir meint er der buchstabe
ist lassen da sind dann macht man das
und das dahin
das ist ganz cool hier sieht nämlich
jetzt auch mal das crafting rezept
eingeblendet und zwar oben drein ender
perlen in die mitte ein obsidian links
und rechts von obsidian zwei sticks und
unten drei diamanten dann bekommt man
halt schon etwas bläulichen blaze rott
däne der auch schon eingeblendet seht da
die man dann halt herausbekommt dass ich
halt immer so ein bisschen rum pixel ich
bin nicht so gut im pixeln das kann
andere leute besser aber
ich denke so fürs für den vorfeld reicht
es eigentlich und zwar kann man damit
dann einfach irgendwie auf einen mob ich
habe quasi sind starke hand und kann
quasi auf einen scharf rechts weg machen
und dann bin ich dieser mob und kanal
scharf rumlaufen
das ist eventuell ganz cool weil krieger
habe mir angst vor katzen und wenn man
sich dann in eine katze verwandelt ganz
beispielsweise wenn man eine katze hat
dann kribbelt form ab es ist eine etwas
ja ich würde schon sagen unnötige sache
es wäre allerdings ganz witzig wenn so
ein teil mal hinzugefügt ich würde es
mir nicht unbedingt wünschen dass es in
vanilla kommt aber ich fand es ganz
coole idee und er hat einfach und coolen
kommentar geschrieben und sich darüber
gedanken gemacht wie man diesen stark
gemacht und das war die fünfte sache
das war schon wieder mit den kräften
ideen heute im samstag es tut mir leid
ist das video ein bisschen später kam
aber ich bin es um 14 uhr aufgestanden
weil ich gestern nach bis 5 bar und also
wenn ihr crafting ideen habt dann
schreibt sie mir doch bitte einfach
unten in die kommentare
bei mir da ganz viele crafting den rhein
und eventuell seht ihr dann in der
nächsten folge dabei und dann würde ich
sagen wenn es euch denn gefallen hat und
ihr mehr von crafting ideen und diesen
ganzen serien die ich in letzter zeit
haben wie beispielsweise top 5 in
irgendwas oder dies oder das oder micro
triple haben wollt zeigt es mir mit
einer bewertung schaut in der
beschreibung vor beide sind eine ganz
sozialen netzwerke und wir sehen uns
dann in einem anderen video